en un peligroso recorrido por los
frentes de batalla en Ucrania la misión
Tulipán negro un grupo de alrededor de
100 voluntarios se propuso buscar y
exhumar los cuerpos de soldados caídos
en combate para devolverlos a sus
familias Y darles un último adiós
mientras que los ataques continúan
cuando nos sentaremos a nuestros
muchachos creo que estamos haciendo una
buena obra pueden ser enterrados
adecuadamente según la tradición ya sea
en el Rito funerario cristiano o la otra
creencia no deben quedar abandonados en
algún bosque campo o en la calle
entre tanto la fiscalía ucraniana
informó sobre el hallazgo de otra cámara
de tortura en la región de nikolife
liberada de la ocupación rusa según el
reporte oficial cientos de civiles
fueron detenidos y torturados
brutalmente por negarse a cooperar con
las tropas rusas mientras que la guerra
se mantiene activa en el este y el sur
del país las labores de identificación
de cadáveres son peligrosas ya que a
menudo se encuentran cuerpos con de
armas explosivas o incluso trampas
las circunstancias actuales son
incomprensibles no puedo entenderlas
estamos en El Siglo 21 hay Guerra y los
cuerpos yacen a lo largo de las
carreteras en los bosques y en los
edificios en ruinas
la misión Tulipán negro ya había
realizado labores de identificación de
restos humanos de la Segunda Guerra
Mundial en Alemania encontrando más de
3.000 cuerpos ahora en Ucrania La
cantidad es incalculable y Su futuro
incierto